you should really go to a retirement
home one day and volunteer and just talk
to them it will make you want to do [ __ ]
every minute in your life because when
you see regret in a man's eyes
it's [ __ ] painful because you have
can't do [ __ ] about it
when you're 90 and you're not mobile and
you're tired and it's over you can't do
it you can't do it you can't build that
company you want it you can't spend that
time with your kid you it's regret and
it [ __ ] drives the [ __ ] out of me
how are you good
what's cooking how's the Year going what
it radio do what did TV do I think when
you I think what what's gonna the
pavements can hit here is how are you
measuring all the other activities right
so everybody loves to say you're right
and that's the plan that's why I went
there Mazel Tov that you want us to
prove our fifty thousand dollars on
Facebook soul [ __ ] but I want to
understand how your four hundred
thousand on print catalog or whatever a
portion you're doing is selling because
you have to change that to have a fair
conversation Gary it's so hard to be in
a meeting with you I know I rail right I
railroad um it's so hard it's uh it is
just never feel pretty enough thanks to
you Gary which is so which is so
inappropriate cuz you're so pretty I
love it it's been a while since I've
seen the action right if I'm like year
to huh it's maximizing that lets you
steal [ __ ] there most weekends because
you can take very good do I work so much
I don't do that I won't have a family
exactly yeah must be at Oakland it is
tough finish top Anna Anna Epson flows
like they're getting older now and I'm
taking more time no older kids seven
four okay see they're starting to become
real people you know your desperation
thank you my inspiration thank you
what's your name John John good for you
yeah let's do it you have to chop in the
world now wait a bit yeah
lovely stuff thank you say hello hello
talk to you stay well I really like that
me too
I thought the vibes were very good yeah
this who's going
what's up man else thank you nice to see
you good take a quick cell to work right
sorry to it that's okay it's okay
enjoy woman what's your name Jonas Jonas
nice to meet you man
thanks for saying hello what are you
doing I we have an office here so just
doing business
I've left most places right oh my god we
look great we we like terrible well we
look amazing you look terrible I look
phenomenal yeah well I guess you look
phenomenal
no and I look terrible as a girl that's
so amazing
Wow let's yep awesome cool talk to you
nice
hahaha I still I can't see it although
heinel hyper I love it
you know many times this has been shot
to me uh-huh
this is um I've had so many people take
this picture for me that's awesome
hello how are you good
I'm Gary oh hi yeah how are you Peter
glad peter is such a pleasure how are
you so who came first you me I think
yeah I think you if it's 88 I checked my
I changed the name in 96 so definitely
you a real pleasure
real pleasure how are you yes good good
so many people send me that picture of
your sign I literally through the years
yeah
awesome yeah what I gotta do some
shopping
yeah awesome soon again
good
just doing some new business meetings
somebody's got to make money around here
all good stuff
you know why I'll tell you why wine was
such a homerun for me I'm a story I love
storytelling and wine is the perfect
like you know crazy wine is there's
unlimited products and they change every
year like not like not only are there
like like a million in one stories but
like the story between this wine and
2013 and this one in 2014 has a whole
other story
you get to talk about like the rain and
the Sun or like how they farmed it that
year it's it's it's unlimited and plus
the other thing that's fun about
storytelling is um is you love to tell
stories in categories where people are
intimidated so like people are really
intimidated by wine by the label
intuitively like a sign that says
something about Watson wine for the UH
for the London office rhyme Meg's good
good you did it so well you snuck in
comes here damn well no well stir I'd
love to get you to goodbye let me show
you this ironically since we did be in
the world I've not been able to follow
the content as closely because this is
so busy yeah it's almost like the
graduation of following you is to stop
following you I you know to get it do I
get it you know I put out content like
that's all I talk about
of course that's the that's the I mean
watching that makes me smile yeah I know
what that is yeah and so of course Sorry
mate is it come 5d should be strong
enough it's okay really considerate
course
oh that's gonna make it that's gonna
make it I see yeah and this right in my
car but I gotta go to sweetie alright
always good to see you man see you soon
talk to you soon brother
Hotel ice up for two hours and that's it
so I only have three I'm on three hours
of sleep well I'll be and then I'll and
that and then I'm leaving then imma
leave Oh who's that right was that
awesome
yeah yeah it's really cool
well great so thanks for getting
together and there's a lot of fun
jamming in LA yeah I guess on the back
of when you really look at the business
how many buckets can the business play
in that is up sizable meaning this for
you to spend money to create and deploy
in the roof
this is nice
what actually CR
I think that's very subjective to the
end-user I think that um I think that uh
way too many people want to be the judge
and the jury of high quality content but
at the end of the day high quality
content is completely answered by the
audience that it's trying to reach so
for example as you can imagine with me
I'm an aggressive Jersey guys sometimes
I curse on my content a lot of people in
a certain demo and definitely in a
certain mindset think it's very high
quality if not the most high quality
business content on the internet then
there's a lot of other people that are
conservative and are you know quote
unquote more professional buttoned up
that see me wearing a t-shirt and
cursing and think it's the lowest
quality right that it's crass so I think
I think that um I think that it's super
important to recognize that high quality
content is judged by the market that the
content is trying to reach yeah I think
I I think that's a that's an interesting
place to take it I do think that content
that is from a personal look I think any
personal brand any individual that is an
acting mode is creating vulnerability
and I think that the more you are who
you are the more upside you have with
what you're doing good to see it's good
to say I'm in I'm good kill you I mean
really well yeah I'm glad he made it
tonight well thank you I'm sorry I'm
starting to realize like everybody's
saying I didn't realize ten o'clock was
an unusual thing in London so I'm like
confident I'm like so proud of the
turnout it should be fun I'll get it
start in a minute okay right thank you
so much for coming together Eric and I
were talking about my next trip to
London I said you know what I want to do
something that I've been doing for a
long time with with a bunch of new
friends people that have maybe met once
or twice and this turnout was super fun
I think you guys didn't really enjoy
this what I'm about to tell you about is
probably the singular reason I still go
to conferences so I'm going to start
this by telling you a story in South by
Southwest 2008 that was the year when it
was starting to get bigger Twitter
popped the year before and there was
like three times more people that came
to South by than the year before
and of course anybody that's come before
you know how you hate when anything
sells out it's like a band or anything
of that nature Oh
people like oh it's selling out it's so
crowded there was lines to actually get
into a party so what happened was that
night me and my friend Travis who went
on to become the co-founder and CEO of
uber and my friend Kevin Rose who is
probably the face of the whole web 2.0
movement at the time as a CEO of Digg
and so and so that night hey Lars how
are you so that night said yeah pull up
another chair rice uh that night we all
went into a hotel room with dave McClure
who went on to start 500 startups a big
venture fund and five or six other
people see uh one of the cofounders of
LivingSocial and we called it the jam
session really cool stuff like so many
fun inside jokes one of the so one of
the big things that we try to do and one
of the things I'll be fun tonight is you
all get to know each other maybe you'll
do it more often
I think I'm planning on doing a bunch
here in London I want to make it kind of
a thing it's fun to see who is right and
wrong
like I genuinely believe that IP is the
most underpriced asset and like Marvel
really really struck me and they're like
just the Pokemon go I get a lot of
credit to the IP I think even this
entire table this room grossly
underestimate the speed in which
technology is actually gonna happen like
when you really just take a step back
and think about where the world was just
ten years ago so many of the things that
we talk about as a day-to-day base
infrastructure cost of entry to what we
live in today didn't exist when you
project-- out ten more years of
technology like it's just so
extraordinary I don't think we sit here
three months ago and think there's that
many tens of millions of users using an
AR app in 90 days and just wake up one
morning and over a weekend it's real I
just think there's a lot of that going
on that I think is gonna be really
fascinating to say I am a complete
believer that the world is built on the
shadows of our society that they're an
equal important infrastructure I mean
even what's going on in the US right now
like because of live-streaming and and
where the internet is and media is like
where we as a country have to start
facing some of our real issues that we
don't want to face I just feel like
everything you do is on the record
I think privacy is fundamentally dead
and I just live within that context
tonight in the past maybe like mom was
like old people like really told you
about your relationship and I can be
recording nothing like you should really
go to a retirement home one day and
volunteer and just talk to them it won't
make you wanna do [ __ ] every minute of
your life because when you see regret in
a man's eyes it's [ __ ] painful because
you can't do [ __ ] about it when you're
90 and you're not mobile and you're
tired and it's over you can't do it you
can't do it you can't build that company
wanted you can't spend that time with
your kidney its regret and it [ __ ]
drives the [ __ ] out of me it just drives
the living [ __ ] out of it you know what
I mean I think it go with that fountain
how old are you 26 you got [ __ ] time
it's a it's a balance of regret and
patience like you can go hard on for
three years do nothing right wake up and
be young as [ __ ] like I'd ripped my arm
off to be 35 five years like take it you
know yeah yeah no that would be the
biggest thing I would tell you like
school yeah I mean yeah yeah and
recognize where you are in the system
right obviously anybody can have a
tragic thing but you're young man and
you got a lot of time so it's like
pulling equally from like ambition and
no regret but equally being patient
they're contradictions and finding the
balance in the two is where all the
magic is
12:24 I'm heading out I don't need you
follow me to the hotel and go to sleep
see ya